[音楽]
ん
ああああああ
voodoo
re ある
あなたはどこに生まれますよと神様が
決めるくじがあるとする
その手がもし右に2ミリずれていたとし
たら
私はビバリーヒルズの金文字店部だったか
もしれない
もしもその手が左に1mm 連れていたと
したら
私は泣きながら夜道を駆け回るスラム街の
孤児だったかもしれない
私が今ここに生きているということ
あなたが今そこに生きているということ
何一つ
当たり前じゃない
これは私が小学校6年生のときに書いた
作文の中の言葉です
本人は何一つ悪くないのに生まれてしまっ
た環境のせいで苦しまなければならない人
たちがたくさんいる
そんな社会への怒りのようなものを常に
抱えていて貧しい人のために私の命を使う
ということが私の生まれた意味なのだと
思っていますか
そんな思いが強くなれば強くなるほど私は
世の中から置いてきぼりにされるんじゃ
ないかというような気持ちも多くなって
いきました
勇気を持って私が考えていることを話して
みても
はそういうことはお片付けのできるように
なってから言ってくれんかなぁ
ちょっとナンバー良い夜か分から
話を聞いてくれる人がいないということ区
象瀬頑張ってもこんな長崎のな片隅で
頑張っても周りに潰されて諦めちゃうん
じゃないかなーという恐怖
そんな感情を打ち消すためまた貧困状態に
ある子どもたちは世界にいるんだよという
ことを伝えるために様々な活動をしてき
ました
フィリピンに行った時はスラム街やろ所
鑑別所で暮らす子どもたちの声を頂いて
それを日本中にいる
日本中に伝えたりしてきました
地元では地域格差の改善のため学生団体を
立ち上げたりしました
インドに1年間留学した時はアウト
カーストの子供たちを主役にした
ファッションショーを行いました
また国内の分断や格差への問題提起のため
文章を執筆したりもしてきました
そんな私が大学1年生になって今思って
いることそれは貧困問題の解決のために
一番やらなきゃいけないことは話を聞いて
もらえない人の話を聞くということつまり
あの時の私が周りにして欲しかったことな
のではないかという事ですまたそれは
私たちが日常生活の中から簡単に取り組ん
でいけることなのではないかということ
です
今日は世界を変えたかった私があなたの話
を聞きたい理由というテーマでお話をして
いきます
中学校2年生の頃のことです
私はある古民家で行われた台湾の教室と
いうのに参加しました
先生はいうのです
目の前にいる人と英語で好きなものについ
て話をしてみて
だけど
私の目の前にいたのは英語がほとんど
分からないという40代の女性が一人
英語がわからないという人と英語で
コミュニケーションをとる
そんなことなんてできるんだろうか
私は恐る遅い話しかけました
ウォッチ are free
wedding 知立
相手は何も反応しません
すぐに無理でしというような視点を先生に
投げかけます
先生はいうのです
とりあえず向き合ってみなさい
そこで私はどこからか本を取り出して指を
させていました
っていういうはいっ
北
彼女はこくこくと頷きます
ooo 線 due ビッグブック
彼女を反応しません
ウォンズ
ゆうゆう wii ブック
すると彼女はこう言いました
前
i いっ
息子
go 2期
週刊バー
相愛きゃんっ
中間バーというのはキュウリという意味
です
私の息子はキュウリに行きます
日本語で聞くとなんだかおかしな文章です
が当時の私は全く笑おうとは思いません
でした
相手の生活を想像しながら何を伝えて
くれようとしているのかを考えます
中
銀柳街で幼稚園 iscsi てはパッド
笑顔になりました
今はお読みになるんですかはい
5お読みになるんですか
息子がいいを前にとるもんですから
あんまり時間がなくてから読む時間のなか
とですよ
日本語で聞くとそんな聞こうともしなくて
いいような内容です
しかしながらそれが英語になることによっ
て自分から前のめりにならないと
コミュニケーションがとれないと必死に
なりました
相手にとって分かりやすい言葉って何
だろう
相手は日々どういう生活をしているの
だろうか
そういうことを想像する過程において私は
気がつきました
私は最初
ただ得意な英語を人前で話したいと思って
いただけなのではないかとなると今まで
支えはだと思っていたものはただの自分が
言いたいことの一方的な発表髪はだったの
ではないかということに
またまたこういうこともありました
高校3名性ある政府の分科会に参加した
ときのことです
プログラムプログラミング教育においては
生徒自身のデバイスを使って
現在書くことや話すことといった
アウトプットの授業が盛んに行われている
と思いますが
様々な公教育についての議論が活発に行わ
れています
しかし私はどこかその色に含まれていない
ような感じがしたのです
私は恐る恐る言いました
あの
公教育とはどこの公教育を想定してお話
でしょうか
私の周りでは自分のパソコンとか思って
いる人は一人もいないですし
話すこととか聞く話すことや書くことと
言ったアウトプットがすでに促進されて
いるような文脈のように受け取れたんです
けど
私たちの学校ではそれが促進されていると
感じるどころかそれが許されているような
場面もすごく少なかったりするんですけど
すると政治家の方は笑いながらこういった
のです
まあね山部さんはマイノリティだからね
そこらへんは僕たち想定してないんだよ
あなたの話は私たちの要点ではない
彼はそういった買ったのでしょうか
しかしながら私たちが話していたのは公
教育についてです
公教育に含まれている含まれていないも
あるでしょうか
私は思いました
彼は自分の前提が覆されることを遠藤に
思っていないだろうか
またまたこんなこともありました
愛知の会議に参加したときのことです
男性が17人女性は私1人だけ
雨古民家で学んだ時のように目を見て
伝えようという気持ちを持って話します
するとどうでしょう
まったく話を聞いてもらえません
私が何を言っても途中で遮られたり話を
すり替えられたりして最後まで私が話す
ことは一度もできませんでした
まあね君は社会経験がないから
何を言われてもやっぱり遮られてしまい
ます
次の会議からは私はいつもより眉毛を太く
濃く書いてリップはブラウンを選んで声は
いつもより低めで行くことにしました
前日の夜はシミュレーションをして戦闘
態勢で社会へ向かいます
途中で声をかぶせられそうになってもそれ
よりももっともっと大きな声を出してある
家聞こえないふりをしてそのまま話し
続ける
相手がつまらない冗談を言っても絶対に
笑わないだってそこで笑ってしまったら私
は話を聞く担当になってしまって話を聞い
てもらえなくなるからです
同じ土俵に守れなくなってしまうからです
そうするとどうでしょう
話を聞いてもらおうとするのに労力を使い
すぎて話の内容にまで
話の内容にまで手を回すことができなく
なってしまいました
私は思いました
その人にとっては話を聞いてもらえると
いうことが当たり前なのだろうか
自分のことを正しいと思わせてくれる人に
囲まれているのだろうかと
もしある特定の集団の中に今日者と弱者が
いるとすればそれは話を当たり前のように
聞いておられる人と話しをあと当たり前の
ように聞いてもらえない人のことを言うの
ではないか
自分がいつも一緒の一緒にいる人と話す
ときは伝え落としなくても伝わります
聞こうとしなくてもわかります
とっても楽です
しかしながら自分が話が通じる人とだけ
話していると
自分の当たり前6外にいる人たちの生活が
見えなくなります
自分が当たり前に持っているものを持た
ない人たちの痛みお話を聞く機会を失い
ます
すると
もしそうやって
人々が固まるようになったら
話を聞いてもらえない人の話は一体誰が
効くのでしょうか
引いてもらえず共感してもらえず問題だと
思われずお金を使われず
その問題は
一生解決されないままです
こうやって話を聞かないということは新婚
問題にもつながっていきます
誰からも話を聞いてもらえず社会に
置き去りにされている
社会にオフィされにされているように感じ
ている人こういう人たちの声を皆に聴いて
ほしい
学校の先生だったり会社の社長さんだっ
たり何かの役員さんだったり何かの
リーダーだったり
そういうふうな人たちが彼らの現状を知る
ことによって適切な支援が回るようにし
たい
周りから認められることによって彼らが
自信を持てるようにしたい
進行問題を解決したいと願い続け叫び続け
た私が最終的にたどり着いた答えはここ
でした
ここで話している聞くというのは何も新婚
状態にある人ない人といった分かりやすい
関係性の話だけではありません
むしろ私たちの日常生活からこそ
分かり分かり合えないと思われるような人
たちの声をより引いていくべきだと思い
ます
それはなぜか
その小さな小さな積み重ねによって私たち
の当たり前から最も遠くにいる人最も
分かり合えなさそうな人たちの話を聞く時
の受け入れるときの新2区を身につける
ことができるからです
また私たちの日常生活の中にも
花集私たちの日常生活の中にも問題を抱え
ている人貧困状態にいやる人はいるかも
しれません
ただ普段は話してくれないだけでいい
石常生活の中でも
らんダン耳を覚ませているとそういう人
たちが私たちの近くにもいたということを
分かるようになる日が来るかもしれません
この人何言ってるんだろう聞く価値がない
な
そう思ったことがあるよという方はどれ位
いらっしゃいますか
もしいらっしゃるとしたらそれはチャンス
です
なぜかというとそれは自分が普通に生きて
いたらせしないような人と話しているよと
いうサインだからです
ちょっと何言ってるかわからないな
そうにが悪い人になったらちょっと
ストップ
一度深呼吸をして
相手と自分が共に生きることができると
信じてみてください
相手の中に近づきたいと願ってみて
ください
相手の話を前のめりに聞いて相手に自分を
チューニングしてみてください
相手の生活
相手の日常を想像してみてください
かつて話を聞いてもらえなくて悲しかった
私は今東京で一人暮らしをしています
周りにお話を聞いてくれる友達しかいなく
てとても幸せです
しかしながらあの時感じていたわかりあえ
なさの正体を知るためにわざと分かり合え
なさそうな人と話をするようにしています
はさは生活保護を受けている方の話を聞き
に行きます昼は秋葉原で使用済み下着を
売っている人達の話を土に行きます
夜は六本木の28会で中華をおごって
もらいながら
社長さんのお話を聞きます
またその次の朝は同じ海外大に進学する
ハーバードやスタンフォードの友達とお話
をします
昼はスラム街の子どもたちと一緒に日でも
ちょっと押します
よりは入国管理局に収容されている方々の
お話を聞きに行きます
今まで私は自分の納得の出来ない人の話に
は常に耳を押さえていました
なぜならば自分自分が大切にしているもの
社会を変えたいという思いを絶対に壊され
たくなかったからです
しかしながら私は気づきました
世の中に理不尽が合う理由はの中に私が
納得のできないことが起こる理由は私が
納得のできない考え納得のできない人が
いるからではないか
進行問題を生み出している社会を理解する
には
新婚問題オス貧困問題を理解するには進行
問題を生み出している社会のことをまず
理解しないといけない社会のことを理解
するには社会を構成している一人一人の
ことをまず理解しないといけない
その一心で絶対に納得ができないあなたの
ことを理解したいと今日もドアを開けて外
に飛び出します
皆さんも是非
納得の出来そうにないあの子の話を聞いて
みてください
なった地なくてもいいんです
ただ
理解すれば
その力はきっとあの神様の気まぐれなくじ
をも覆す大きな力となるはずです
聞いてくださってありがとうございました
[拍手]